The answer is the third choice.
The first choice doesn't work, because it assumes Bob knows Alice's private key.
If Bob knows Alice's private key, then it's not Alice's private key anymore.
The second choice doesn't work because the message is being assigned
using Bob's public key.
There's nothing that proves that it came from Alice.
In the third choice, the message is being encrypted using Alice's private key,
which only Alice should have.
Anyone who has Alice's public key, which includes Bob,
can then decrypt the message.
Then if it decrypts to a reasonable message, they know that it came from Alice.
The correctness of this depends on the inverse property that we saw on the previous quiz.
That in order for signatures to work, we need to be able to do encryption and decryption
in the reverse order and have them still be inverses using the appropriate private key
private key for decryption and public key for encryption.